have you guys seen Joaquin Phoenix's
speech that's been going around yeah so
he was accepting his award at the BAFTAs
and he basically asked us it didn't it's
an acting award show it's another one of
those he basically got on stage and he
very awkwardly talked about how he's a
part of the problem in Hollywood because
he is a white actor who has been
supported by Hollywood but Hollywood
hasn't done the same for people of color
I mean I disagree with that just take
your hair can award Joker to be here
tonight Baptists have always been very
supportive of my career and I'm deeply
appreciative but I have to say that I
also feel conflicted because so many of
my fellow actors that are deserving
don't have that same privilege I think
that we send a very clear message to
people of color that you're not welcome
here I think that's the message that
we're sending to people that have
contributed so much to our media melaku
in our industry and in ways that we
benefit from I don't think anybody wants
a handout or preferential treatment
although that's what we give ourselves
every year I think that people just want
to be acknowledged and appreciated and
respected for for their work this is not
a self-righteous condemnation who is
Greta
because I'm ashamed to say that I'm part
of the problem I have not done
everything in my power to ensure that
the sets I work on are inclusive but I
think that it's more than just having
sets that are multicultural I think that
we have to really do the hard work to
truly understand systemic racism I I
think that it is the
obligation of the people that have
created and perpetuate and benefit from
a system of oppression to be the ones
that dismantle it
so that's on us thank you
okay all right I think that's happening
in a lot of ways I mean I mean I know
what I mean I don't think I'm Caesar or
Hollywood
I think Hollywood is in comparison to a
lot of other places and parts the world
Hollywood's pretty good agree I mean III
I'm not sure what else you want
Hollywood Hollywood started as a white
male dominated you know I mean if you
really want to get into it I suppose
Hollywood started as hot white male and
Jewish okay because there was a
tradition in that culture of artistic
individuality and expression and so
that's what happened that's who built
Hollywood and Hollywood is now exporting
product to people all over the world and
it makes economic sense to diversify
story and the people that tell those
stories you have Asian you have black
but I think that hollywood's doing a
pretty good job I would suggest do what
the marketplace wants there are plenty
of people of quote-unquote color looks
it annoys me that that's saying who are
looking for stories that reflect their
own experience okay let's all let's see
what the best stories are let them rise
to the top I think a lot of times we get
so worried about this that a lot of
movies that aren't so good get an award
because you know like moonlight and
stuff like that I don't know I mean was
it the best movie I don't know but what
happens is that's that's even a bigger
problem if you're gonna start like Shh
shoehorning in diversity mm-hmm let it
happen organically and I don't know that
anybody at most people in Hollywood that
I've been around I've been here I've
only been here 27 years so I don't know
much but I've I've always noticed how
inclusive it is I think with Joaquin
Phoenix's do some dude I think you do
nothing
this is just again this is just virtual
signaling like you're not going doing
things next time maybe it's a speech and
it's just gives you headlines and then
okay next time they they give you a role
like I now give to that black guy yeah
you know and that's nothing to share
that movie was about mental illness and
and an isolated young men so that's an
important movie and and those people is
girlfriend those people aren't thinking
about white and privileged their girl
things fell out in the movie though yeah
correct
so okay you know I don't know man that
movie was saying something but I don't
think I think and I like that I think
you can do [ __ ] any do [ __ ] yeah any do
anything well bottom lies you can't
drink an award next year if you do the
same movie yes I can do anything
it's also like I'm gonna talk about open
up [ __ ] you know these these homes
for kids yeah you guys can do [ __ ] yeah
you want to I want to get gender
Hollywood is always Hollywood was all
about transgender stuff than they were
all about global warming and they they
they tend to just you know pay and you
know actors want to be liked and so you
know the country knows this the whole
country anytime you have an actor get
behind you it you know when when Taylor
Swift who I saw a documentary on her
which I kind of enjoyed you watch the
documentary a little bit just to see
what she was like you said like that yes
I wanted to okay yeah but she got behind
that this this Martha Blackburn or
whatever the [ __ ] her name is a
Tennessee I'm in a hardcore conservative
really against gay marriage and all that
stuff tell us what said you know why
would you vote why would Tennessee does
she tweeted don't vote for a homophobic
racist you know or something like that
in office and like a bunch of her
followers came out and [ __ ] you know
voted but Marsha Blackburn still 162
percent to 32 percent or whatever
so it it's sometimes if you're a
political candidate having someone like
Sean Penn or whoever it might be in your
corner is a bad idea the country's very
suspicious of actors and should be not
cuz actors are bad people with yellow
not for their emotional Alma faked their
emotion like their employer not real
people to us like they're playing like
why can't see listen man I like walking
thinks he's crazy let's let's get this
he's crazy
yeah legit crazy so it's like all right
here's anxiety you don't like to talk
take him with some agenda yeah you know
yeah you know I probably was a guy like
him he's like I have this opportunity
let me try to say something and make the
world a better place I don't want to
just be an actor and winning this award
and the mistake is be a great actor
which is what you are and and say speak
through your work do it's do a movie
about that maybe you know that's where
you'd get the most impact I don't know
about making a speech but put it in your
work finance a movie that's that that
tells a great story about that and
changes hearts and minds when Harriet
Beecher Stowe wrote Uncle Tom's Cabin
there is the the rumor whether it's true
or not historically that that Abraham
Lincoln said in Europe the little woman
who wrote this book that caused this
great war when you read Uncle Tom's
Cabin and you were and I read it it is
so powerfully it is such a powerful
story against slavery and in people in
the North read and they go this is the
most horrific thing they're selling
children from under their parents but no
and it's in it galvanized the war effort
in the north it was it was a book and it
had a lot to do with why the north stay
historians would argue were able to sort
of get behind this war effort
so criticized by creating my favorite
quotes but also Joaquin Phoenix he's
done all these awards he's touched on
climate change
he's touched on he has said you terian
so it's like yeah he has hasn't he
literally every everyone's a different
agenda well that's a little bit of a
Messiah Complex listen I'm not following
that guy anywhere no I'm gonna make
Joker to a lot so go see a movie you
know make Joker do I'm in
but I'm not like that I'm out dude and I
don't I don't think that's lost on most
people I think most people go hmm first
of all you're calling all this racists
are part of the problem
uh-huh I don't feel that way I'm not
that I'm not a racist I'm not even a
little bit racist and I try to do the
best I can with what I have and that
means that's why I'm opening a number of
orphans and then his uh during the globe
speech he got tweet got blurred most of
it you didn't see at home cuz he yelled
out there's no [ __ ] best actor well
just take the award dude the other is
theirs though yeah there is and you were
it you were great just take it man I
mean I take it easy can't take the love
you know here so I mean yeah he's got
he's gonna his therapist probably got
Jesus girl yeah there's a think you're
right about that
he's a very disturbed is just like yeah
I from what I understand hi what do you
got man he won all these awards yes
still not happy yep yep I told you all
right let's unravel this he's a very
very sensitive mind Stan and delicate
fella his social anxieties don't like to
give talked so he had to come up with
some sort of spiel though he looks like
he's holding his breath the whole time
you know yeah mm-hmm
phenomenal actor though he's phenomenal
phenomenal he won you did best best boy
is he he looks he looks so much
healthier in that movie he just looked
skinny unhappy rolled oh man he's eaten
again hey what else we get crazy crazy
is gonna crazy right it's crazy it's
gonna crazy it's gonna crazy Tigers
gonna [ __ ] bite and touch he's gonna
Chris I got a bite
crazy gonna crazy I mean he's also like
playing the game right when I when I saw
this it reminded me of just playing the
Hollywood game this is what you do to
get more you know roll yeah beep liked
by people yeah I just see I see that
like transparent think everyone does
yeah but us when you win six awards in
each six one's a different agenda take a
[ __ ] can watch exactly dude yeah I mean
I work in an ABC there's a huge
diversity initiatives there and and my
sets very colorful my set is incredibly
diverse and credit
and I have to say if you snappy so so
there's something there I think there's
always something that is right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]